merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à madame la Première
ministre pour évoquer notre souveraineté
sanitaire car le sujet est à la fois
économique et sanitaire des pénuries de
médicaments et de dispositifs médicaux
cela fait des années que ça dure mais
aujourd'hui le niveau des manquants a
atteint des sommets c'est du jamais vu
paracétamol et amoxicilline continue de
faire l'actualité et le ministère impose
quant à lui des contingentements mais
aujourd'hui c'est aussi l'un des acteurs
mondiaux des industries de santé le
dernier fabricant français de poche de
perfusion pour les hôpitaux qui est en
redressement judiciaire et qui cherche
un repreneur et si aucun repreneur n'est
trouvé d'ici le 5 janvier alors
l'entreprise risque de fermer
définitivement les hôpitaux s'inquiètent
et n'aient pas besoin de cela comment
demain pourront-ils s'approvisionner en
poche de perfusion
c'est un nouveau symbole de notre
indépendance sanitaire qui est en danger
comment expliquer cela Monsieur le
Ministre et que comptez-vous